have you got any mad stitches on any
issues or like because you know you see
jordan pickford get
get the raven on the side of it you get
any mad ones on for the uh euros or
anything i don't think i'll get anything
that's um
it's a bit crazy on on the sides of the
euros but maybe who knows
you're not saying like a little bit of a
rice rice baby on the side or anything
like that yeah you know what that could
work
rice rice baby that would be a classic
to be fair yeah
that's a good one
[Music]
how are we lads i'm joe gilmore and this
is driplocker on sport bible today we've
got declan rice what's happening
declaration all right
all right mate you're good yeah i'm all
good mates now avid
you've got a hoard of class football
boots so what's the oldest pair that you
own
these are the first ever ever made
like old box 1994
the old tags on everything jeez brand
new with tags as well
brand new with tags mate it's
unbelievable that the old predator sign
like everything about them like the tags
like just the box the stuff it cut that
the little booklet
come in like everything about it is what
i love like just
i could never wear them to be fair i
could never wear them i don't think i
could ever put these on for training
i think he's just got to stay with me
forever so if we move away from them
now let's talk about any crazy boots you
have what would you say is the loudest
pair of boots that you own like
you know the ones you get the most stick
for from the lads it's the accelerator
the gold accelerator
i've actually got two pairs of these wow
one pair that i actually wear one pair
that's
that's fresh tags um but yeah the lads
just say
you can't wear gold boots you can't
actually can't wear that i feel like an
air through the bloody zoom like they
are oh my god
allowed them when we walk out the train
like everyone stands in like a corner
waiting for the fitness coach to take us
off
and if we've got a new pair on that i'll
walk out and all the lads will just be
staring down at my foot guys oh yeah
they're nice
to me they're more yeah they're decent
what about moisey does he
does he wear any flashy boots or is he
just bug standard all blacks
he's all black black and white coppers
that would have rather the brother
yeah he has great banter to be fair like
yeah
if i'm uncomfortable in a boot and i'll
change my boots like halfway through
training he'll go
you can't get your footwear right can
you like having to laugh like a little
bit of banter is quite funny to be fair
and when he sees a bright boot i'm
pretty sure he doesn't like seeing a
bright boot
yeah straight black and white so um yeah
he's at black and white
do you have any boots that like and
you've swapped with another player
like a game or anything like that no i
don't know what if
no unless it was messy or ronaldo i
don't think or
i don't yeah i don't think i'd be asking
them for another pair of boots but i
think that'd be a bit awkward like
yeah can have your boots yeah hey listen
west amateur now you never know you
might be seeing them next season
it's so messy can i take everything the
socks the shoes the pads
um
messy we'll take him any day so what
would you say are your favorite pair of
boots
the beckham pulses
proper proper boots as you can see
because they're like they're so fresh
they go yellow on the
under the sole um yeah what a boot that
is and
with this one i've also got them in blue
as well
which is a prop up like these remind me
of lampard like oh 405 season
would you say that's why they're so
special to you because it reminds you of
those moments
yeah like just the world-class players
you obviously look back on now obviously
in 2021 but you look back on them times
you're watching premier league years you
know you're watching these players
score fantastic goals and they're
wearing these boots and like to have
them now and obviously to
to wear them as well is special but i
want to keep them fresh because you
never know 20 years time
you might not ever be able to get all of
them again for a few quid
exactly exactly i've got to be careful
now i know you might not want to wear
your favorite pair all the time like
because you don't get them wrecked so
what boots are you rocking at the minute
at the minute i'm rocking the new the
new copa which i've got here to hand
which is the latest copa which they've
just brought out um it's really
different you know it's a really
different boot to the last copa
um which which was out i love it it's
all black you know it's got the gold at
the back you know the three stripes
everything about it's amazing there's
like a new tongue on it as well which is
which is really really classy i see you
there got deckers on the side there a
little bit of stitching
yeah yeah is it what's
have you got any mad stitches on any
issues or like is it you know you see
jordan pickford get
get the raven on the side of it you get
any mad ones on for the uh euros or
anything
um nah do you know what it's always just
been either deckers or i've had my three
nephews names on the side of my latest
boots i don't think i'll get anything
that's um
it's a bit crazy on the sides of the
euros but maybe who knows just wait and
see yeah
you got to think of a mad one though
come on we've got to come up with
something good
you're not you're not saying like a
little bit of a rice rice baby on the
side or anything like that yeah you know
what that could work rice rice baby that
would be
a classic to be fair yeah that was a
good one um
i might get on the phone to mike after
and say next boot rice rice baby
yeah here you go sources that will fly
up the oil sometimes
that will fly
the preparation was very good kind of
cristiano ronaldo
style